of course your husband has a lot of
drawbacks
if he had none
he would never marry you
don't be afraid of enemies who attack
you
be afraid of the friends who flatter you
the load of tomorrow
added to that of yesterday
carried today
makes the strongest falter
develop success from failures
discouragement and failure are two of
the surest stepping stones to success
most of the important things in the
world have been accomplished by people
who have kept on trying
when there seemed to be no hope at all
keep busy
it's the cheapest kind of medicine there
is on this earth
and one of the best
remember
today is the tomorrow you worried about
yesterday
our thoughts make us what we are
knowledge isn't power
until it's applied
one reason why birds and horses are not
unhappy
is because they are not trying to
impress other birds and horses
[Music]
personally i am very fond of
strawberries and cream
but i have found that for some strange
reason
fish prefer worms
so when i went fishing i didn't think
about what i wanted
i thought about what fish wanted
two men looked out from prison bars
one saw the mud
the other saw stars
be more concerned with your character
than with your reputation
for your character is what you are
while your reputation is merely what
others
think you are
when fate hands you lemons
make lemonade
remember
happiness doesn't depend upon who you
are or what you have
it depends solely upon what you think
you can make more friends in two months
by becoming interested in other people
then you can in two years by trying to
get other people interested in you
our fatigue is often caused not by work
but by worry
frustration
and resentment
if you want to keep happiness
you have to share it
you'll never achieve real success unless
you like what you are doing
the expression one wears on one's face
is far more important than the clothes
one wears on one's back
inaction breeds doubt and fear
action breeds confidence and courage
if you want to conquer fear
do not sit home and think about it
go out and get busy
[Music]
the successful man will profit from his
mistakes
and try again
in a different way
feeling sorry for yourself and your
present condition
is not only a waste of energy
but the worst habit you could possibly
have
the only way i can get you to do
anything
is by giving you what you want
do the hard jobs first
the easy jobs will take care of
themselves
if you want to change people
why not begin on yourself
that is a lot more profitable and a lot
less dangerous
fear doesn't exist anywhere
except in the mind
act as if you were already happy
and that will tend to make you happy
a smile costs nothing but gives much
are you bored with life
then throw yourself into some work you
believe in with all your heart
live for it
die for it
and you will find happiness that you had
thought could never be yours
the only way to influence people is to
talk in terms of what the other person
wants
keep busy
the worried person must lose himself in
action
lest he wither in despair
three-fourths of the people you will
never meet
are hungering and thirsting for
sympathy give it to them
and they will love you
which quote did you like the most
share your opinion in the comments
one day you will regret that you did not
hear these quotes earlier
do not lose the opportunity
watch our next video